hey guys it's just stayed and today
we're checking out the brand new Mac
Mini I have been a Mac Mini fan since
the very first Mac Mini I actually won
my first Mac Mini on a contest of
MySpace this was super shady the fact
that I actually got a Mac Mini in the
mail and not murdered is shocking to me
I think it was right when I was in
college and I didn't really have a job
so it really definitely didn't have any
money didn't have a computer you really
have much of anything except I guess I'm
a dignity but so let's unbox this it has
many use cases and I feel like for me I
may have a different use case than many
people because I do edit pretty much
everything on my iMac Pro and that thing
is so fast that for me to realistically
use one of these to sort of offload some
compressing from a compressor probably
isn't that realistic because my Mac Pro
I can still compress videos and at at
the same time and usually there's no lag
so that may not be a use case but I do
plan on editing this entire video that
you're watching right now on the Mac
Mini so I'll give you some updates as
this video progresses this now has an
all space gray finish if made of 100%
recyclable aluminum which is pretty
incredible because there's so many
processes that they said they have to go
through to sort of make this aluminum
that is recycled look as perfect as it
does so that's decreasing the carbon
footprint of these products by a pretty
significant amount oh wow it's just
right they're not ready for that too
they also have a larger air vent so that
will help with increased air flow this
one's really good it's smells like
Cupertino like if you're ever in
Cupertino just take a whiff of that
fresh air and this is what it smells
like look at all of these ports this is
definitely something that I'm excited
about especially using my macbook so
often and having to use a dongle just to
be able to actually use my laptop
see what else we have in here little
tiny papers do I not have any stickers
but you always give us sticker here they
are oh wow I was in white the panic
found power cable have you seen one of
these before so here's the power button
here's the port for the power Ethernet
for Thunderbolt 3 USB C ports HDMI and 2
USB 3 s and a headphone jack so some of
the highlights in the new Mac Mini is it
starts out at 4 cores but you can
upgrade to 6 60% faster graphics in the
previous version you can max it out to
64 gigs of ram it also switched all of
the new Mac minis to solid-state drives
so this will also go up to 2 terabytes
[Music]
now that everything is all set up I have
Final Cut installed what I'm gonna do
now is I'm going to start editing this
video that you guys are watching right
now I know I'm always fascinated by
looking at people's final cut timelines
so as I'm editing I'll also show you my
Final Cut timeline of the finished piece
so you guys can check it out I'm also
curious to any of you guys edit Final
Cut
what do you add it on I would love to
know leave them in the comments of below
oh wow this is actually so this was my
MacBook Air video
[Music]
as you can see here's me editing the
video that you're currently watching
this is some weird inception one of the
things that I want to try out is
connecting the Mac Mini to my iMac pro
so if I'm editing or doing something I
can offload rendering to my Mac Mini so
I can continue to do things on my I'm a
pro and I'm excited to test that out
although it's crazy because my Mac Pro
is so fast that a lot of times I will be
compressing something and editing at the
same time and it really doesn't hinder
the performance so that's cool it's an
option during the keynote they had a
stack of them and it looked so awesome
it did actually look like a spaceship
this new space gray color is amazing so
let's watch something I'm actually do
from borrowing Jenna's 4k monitor let's
watch a really great video from this one
channel that I love so much they were
screaming out of their cars I will see
you guys in the next video let me know
in the comments below what you guys
think of the Mac MIDI I would love to
hear some of your use cases do you know
anyone who has a Mac Mini do you have a
Mac Mini for me personally if this may
not be the specific use case that I
would need as a solution for my editing
needs because I do have an iMac Pro I
have a MacBook Pro that I edit when I
travel but this could maybe just be my
new kitchen machine
I think if Jenna lets me keep her
monitor we can it is your gaming wonder
this thing is really nice I can't
believe it I've never gaming on this
before it's nice I have the BenQ ones I
should look into this LG one anyway I'm
getting sidetracked thanks for watching
see you guys in my next video if you
guys enjoyed this video give it a thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe I have
a really fun iPad video coming out for
you very very shortly as soon as I get
done shooting and editing it so look for
that soon I will see you guys later and
don't forget about the MacBook Air or
iPad pro giveaway there's more
information about that video in my
MacBook Air video I'll see you guys
later bye
[Music]
you